how to write a company profile marketing
is hard okay for a lot of entrepreneurs
marketing is one of the hardest things
that they have to do you might be great
at your product your service talking to
customers once they've bought service in
them making them feel happy going going
over and above to exceed their
expectations you're probably really good
at that but marketing is something that
a lot of you are really bad at and and
marketing is hard look at the marketing
around you look at look at marketing
from from entrepreneurs small businesses
all the way up to big companies how many
marketing campaigns do you remember how
many of them leave a lasting mark on you
think about the TV that you just watched
whatever show you watched last night all
the commercials that you saw how many of
you actually remember probably not a lot
because the marketing is not memorable
and that's from big business all the way
down to you as an entrepreneur and you
have an opportunity to stand out and
that comes with your company profile
that's a starting point people want to
know what you do to me marketing is all
about values people want to know what
you stand for they want to know why they
should care make me care quickly because
I'm only watching you for two seconds
and then I'm off to somewhere else so
make me care give me a reason to care
make it personal
whatever business you're in you have to
be about something more important you
have to let that shine through if you
look at Nike they're not selling shoes
shoes are a commodity item you could
sell shoes and buy them off of ebay for
cheap you can you can get them sourced
in China crappy shoes it doesn't matter
you're not they're not selling shoes
what Nike does is they honor athletics
they honor great athletes that's what
you're buying into when you buy a Nike
shoe you feel like you're LeBron James
that's what you're buying into so what
are people buying into when they connect
with you how can they feel that right
away tell me your story you have an
advantage as an entrepreneur
to tell me your story to make it
personal to make it passionate tell me
why you started this company what you
believe in because if you make a boring
company profile like everybody else it's
going to get ignored when was the last
time you saw an exciting memorable
company profile if you're selling lawn
care services you don't want to just say
ABC company we sell ferns and lawns
landscaping and grass cutting and all
the boring stuff snow removal blah blah
blah you just lost me I'm moving on to
somebody else show your picture show
your smiling face or even a video would
be better but if you're shy at least a
picture say hi I'm John I started this
business because I love landscaping I
will care for a year in lawn like it's
my own I got into this because you know
you tell whatever story when you were
five years old your mom gave you a
flower and that reminds you of her all
the time like make it personal touch me
with something make me feel like I want
to know you I want you working on my
lawn that can come through in your
company profile if you make it a
standard boring one you might as well
not have a company profile at all
because people are going to gloss over
it this comes as a result from a
question from Mark who wrote in for my
newsletter list
he said I'm starting a company it's in
real estate and I'm looking forward to
your assistance on making a company
profile listen so you're in real estate
okay hugely competitive field how many
people are in real estate
tons of people it's hard to stand out
but most people do such a bad job nobody
tells a personal story nobody's an
expert at something tell me why you got
into real estate who says that who says
why they got into real estate who has a
personal story that I can connect with
nobody this is your chance
get in there tell me why you love real
estate tell me how you pour yourself
into this business show me some passion
so that when I'm looking for somebody to
work with on real estate I'm going to
pick you over everybody else because you
made a personal connection with me show
me your face
tell me your story tell me how you got
started make me care make me care
because most company profiles don't make
me care they're boring they're useless
keep it simple keep it short you could
do it in a hundred words and make me
feel something you do that you're ahead
of the game I don't know why more people
don't do this we look at we look at the
examples that are out there and we say
oh well this guy is they're not like
that so I'm going to copy him and just
modify it but he's not having success
with his either take the opportunity to
connect with people show your face tell
me about your passion and make me care
that's a winning company profile that's
going to get you some business belief
for those you watching liked the video
please give it a thumbs up below I love
doing these videos for you and your
comments your feedback make me want to
keep going so thank you leave a question
underneath I'll make a video response
thank you so much and I'll see you soon